y
[Música]
muy buenas noches américa latina' a
continuación las noticias más destacadas
hasta esta hora quién france24 continúan
sumándose las reacciones internacionales
tras la detención en nicaragua de 27
líderes estudiantiles y campesinos entre
ellos el líder campesino medardo mairena
quien buscaba participar en las
elecciones presidenciales que están
previstas para el próximo mes de
noviembre
mairena se convierte así en el sexto
político opositor al presidente daniel
ortega y aspirante a la presidencia en
ser detenido por la policía de nicaragua
en una serie de arrestos que suman ya 25
políticos opositores tras las rejas que
dejan en entredicho las garantías para
unos comicios presidenciales
transparentes desde bruselas la unión
europea a través de su alto
representante de la política exterior
josep borrell indicaron que está abierta
entonces la posibilidad de que el bloque
comunitario establezcan sanciones contra
el gobierno del presidente ortega por su
parte desde la oposición nicaragüense
hubo reacciones ante las recientes
detenciones de llevar la ley
hay que seguir me importa lo que nos
pase tendrán que detener a 6 millones de
nicaragüenses pero yo creo que eso
obviamente va a ser imposible porque
aquí todos estamos dispuestos a seguir
adelante la mejor forma de resistencia
es esta es seguir adelante y no les
vamos a faltar al respeto ni a los que
están hoy presos ni a las madres que nos
acompañan que hoy
y en colombia por primera vez la
jurisdicción especial para la paz se
imputó a diez militares y un civil por
la ejecución de 120 personas y también
por la desaparición forzada de otras 24
en hechos ocurridos en la frontera
colombo-venezolana entre los años 2007 y
2008 la magistrada catalina díaz afirmó
que la participación de los indicados
fue determinante en el asesinato de más
de un centenar de personas que estaban
en total estado de indefensión y que
fueron presentadas como bajas de combate
la magistrada díaz también señaló que la
evidencia indica que los acusados son
responsables de crímenes de guerra
homicidio crímenes de lesa humanidad y
desaparición todos de manera sistemática
y vamos ahora está short site en el
estado de florida en eeuu en donde
fueron encontrados cuatro cuerpos más
bajo los escombros del edificio
residencial que parcialmente colapsó el
pasado 24 de junio de esta forma la
cifra de fallecidos aumenta ya a 36
personas y más de un centenar siguen
bajo los restos de esta edificación los
esfuerzos de los equipos de búsqueda han
intensificado los ritmos de trabajo en
las últimas horas pese a la amenaza que
representa el clima cambiante ante la
llegada de la tormenta tropical elsa de
otra parte comenzaron también los
entierros de algunas de las víctimas
y después de un año de suspensión debido
a la pandemia de kobe 19 comenzó la
edición número 74 del festival
internacional de cine de cannes que
reúne lo más destacado de la industria
cinematográfica mundial 24 cintas
compiten por la palma de oro el máximo
galardón que entrega este festival
nuestra enviada especial a khan
erika olavarría nos cuenta más
pormenores de esta primera jornada en el
siguiente reporte normalmente se hace en
mayo pero ahora lo estamos haciendo en
julio en pleno verano por eso también
hace mucho calor y eso hace que haya
mucha gente que está de vacaciones aquí
en la costa azul recordemos que a raíz
justamente a la pandemia hay muchos
franceses que no han salido al
extranjero se han quedado en este país y
obviamente la costa azul es un destino
de preferencia así que el ambiente está
aunque obviamente hay menos prensa y
menos festivaleros como se le conoce al
público del festival una alfombra roja
tradicional la única diferencia es que
periodistas y camarógrafos tenían una
mascarilla obviamente negra además
porque desde las 5 de la tarde en todos
los eventos oficiales santiago se pide
una mascarilla negra para que obviamente
no desentonar con la elegancia de este
festival y así llegamos al final de esta
actualización
224 siga con nosotros buenas noches